[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de débat en
franche comté de la maternelle au lycée
il veut tout changer ou presque jean
michel blanquer r le ministre de
l'éducation nationale multiplie les
réformes crispant une partie des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves
alors de quoi ces derniers ont-ils peur
pourquoi notre école doit elle être
réformé à quoi vont ressembler les cours
donnés à nos enfants demain en vendée
battre jusqu'à midi avec nos trois
invités je vous les présente tout de
suite fait naître charvier député la
république en marche du doubs vous êtes
rapporteur du projet de loi sur l'école
de la confiance à l'assemblée nationale
également sur ce plateau nathalie fabre
secrétaire académique du snes fsu et le
snes et le syndicat national des
enseignements du second degré à vos
côtés sandrine claude présidente de la
fcpe du territoire de belfort
vous êtes aussi coordinatrice régionale
académique de la fédération des conseils
de parents d'élèves bonjour à toutes les
trois merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors comme chaque semaine
noté du spectateur aussi peuvent
participer à cette émission vous pouvez
devant votre télé nous faire part de vos
réflexions de vos questions sur la page
internet de l'émission sur le site de
france 3 franche comté je me ferai
d'ailleurs le relais de vos questions
tout au long du débat et puis vous
pouvez aussi commenter l'émission en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
mot ds dit mme paul fc comme dimanche en
politique franche comté alors mesdames
il ya d'abord eu cette réforme du lycée
et du baccalauréat qui sera mise en
oeuvre à la rentrée prochaine et qui est
accusé notamment de fragiliser les
établissements du monde rural
il est ensuite ce projet de loi sur
l'école de la confiance vente votée à
l'assemblée nationale et qui arrive en
ce moment même au sénat un texte qui
crée la polémique jugée comme menaçant
la liberté d'expression des enseignants
et plaçant sous tutelle des écoles
bientôt regroupés autour d'un même
collège
et pourtant et pourtant le président de
la république ne cesse de ré le répéter
l'école est sa priorité
investir dans l'école c'est la première
politique de lutte contre les injustices
dans notre pays disait encore emmanuel
macron lors de sa conférence de presse
la semaine dernière
andrine claude un président de la
république qui fait de l'école sa
priorité est il un bon président il ne
m'appartient pas de répondre par
l'affirmative ou la négative mais on
peut être aussi s'interroger sur le fait
que nous sortons d'un grand débat
national et que dans ce grand débat il
n'y avait guère de place pour
l'éducation
donc il faudrait peut-être un petit peu
rester cohérent sur ce sujet quand on
veut investir dans l'école et dans une
réelle école de la confiance on entend
et on écoute ce que vous semblez dire
c'est qu'il ya les paroles d'un côté les
actes de l'autre c'est très clairement
ça oui les paroles sont très jolies
elles peuvent être très rassurante pour
des parents qui ne sont pas engagés
comme nous le sommes toutes les trois
autour de cette table mais la sémantique
est importante et la sémantique ne dit
pas forcément que tout va être aussi
rose et merveilleux que ce qu'on nous
annonce nathalie faivre emmanuel macron
à dédoubler les classes en zone
prioritaire les classes les petites
classes on va dire il promet de limiter
le nombre d'élèves à 24 par classes de
la grande section au ce1 ils s'engagent
à ne plus fermer d'école sans l'accord
du maire concerné vous dites bravo je
dirais bravo s'il avait précisé comment
il va faire pour financer tout ça parce
que pour l'instant ce que nous avons
constaté depuis que macro et tout
pouvoir c'est que tout ce qui a été fait
pour le primaire sont des moyens qui ont
été prélevées au second degré donc si
c'est déshabiller pierre pour habiller
paul ça ne sera pas efficace en termes
d'éducation
c'est à dire que si les élèves qui
sortent du primaire dans quelques années
on est effectivement un socle d'acquis
plus solide qu actuellement mais qu'ils
arrivent dans une structure collèges et
lycées totalement comment désincarné et
risque de régresser et d'oublier ce
qu'ils ont appris à l'être charvier vous
entendez les craintes de
vos deux interlocutrices j'entends
effectivement les craintes mais je crois
qu'il faut quand même rappeler que le
budget de l'éducation nationale c'est le
premier budget de la france et qu'il y à
un effort d'investissement sans
précédent sur le primaire pourquoi parce
que on constate que le primaire et sous
investis et qu'on investit alors par
rapport aux pays de l' ocde ont investi
14 % de moins que d'autres pays
européens dans le primaire et ensuite on
s'interroge on se dit mais pourquoi est
ce que on a 20 % de nos élèves qui ne
maîtrisent pas les savoirs fondamentaux
quand on ne maîtrise pas les savoirs
fondamentaux lire écrire compter comment
voulez-vous pouvoir envisager de réussir
ensuite au collège ou au lycée donc
l'investissement effectivement la
priorité elle est aujourd'hui sur le
primaire j'aimerais répondre à cela que
en termes de pourcentage du pib la
france n'est pas dans les pays en tête
de peloton
c'est à dire que c'est à peu près 5,8
pour cent du pib alors que dans d'autres
pays
honte à plus de 6 et quand on fait le
détail on se rend compte que ces
dépenses d'éducation sont de plus en
plus restreinte pour l'état et sont de
plus en plus compensés par des dépenses
des familles donc de dire vous avez un
exemple
c'est à dire que les familles consacrent
de plus en plus d'argent à des cours de
rattrapage du soutien etc
par contre les dépenses de l'état en
termes d'éducation ont tendance à abc
l'état consacre moins en termes de
pourcentage du pib à l'éducation
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
si on veut comparer avec les autres pays
le taux d'encadrement de nos élèves
notamment dans les petits dans les
petites classes je préciser le taux
d'encadrement c'est le drôle le nombre
d'adultes pour classe voilà est très
faible en france par rapport à d'autres
pays
sandrine claude je reviens sur l'
annonce de la semaine dernière dont on a
beaucoup parlé dans les médias et cela
vous concerne parce que cela fait des
années que notamment dans notre région
les parents d'élèves se mobilisent
contre les fermetures de classes les
fermetures d'écoles
l'engagement du président de la
république de ne plus fermer aucune
école sans l'assentiment du maire
concerné c'est une bonne chose jean
michel blanc car disait il ya quelques
jours la non fermeture d'écoles
primaires c'est une mesure historique
certainement historique
faut-il que ça soit vraiment cela dans
les faits nos mères aujourd'hui quelle
que soit la grosseur de la commune
investisse dans les écoles et
s'interrogent toujours quand il ya une
menace de fermeture à minimes ils
demandent de pouvoir avoir quelque chose
de plus longs en temps devant eux
puisque ces investissements sont coûteux
pour un budget de la commune et les très
très rare pendant 14 ans de militantisme
je n'ai jamais entendu un maire dira je
suis d'accord pour qu'on ferme et mon
école
c'est quand même une évidence voilà
c'est un service public que l'on rend
aux habitants d'une commune et surtout
pour eux aussi les habitants des
communes rurales
je voulais dire on répond aussi aux
questions des internautes
et on en a beaucoup depuis le début de
la semaine notamment cette réflexion de
fées triesman qui nous dit si réformer
c'est réduire les moyens et lancer des
annonces pour faire croire qu'on a
réinventé la roue
non merci fanette servier les réformes
de jean michel blanquer
ce sont des réformes d'abord pour faire
des économies pas du tout pas du tout ce
sont vraiment des réformes pour rendre
le nôtre notre système plus juste
un des enseignements également de l'
ocde c'est que l' ocde nous placent
régulièrement dans la moyenne des pays
dans les enquêtes pisa par exemple sont
les enquêtes qui mesure le niveau des
élèves dans
chaque pays à un niveau égal on va dire
tout à fait sauf que quand on creuse un
petit peu on se rend compte qu'en fait
chaque année les bons élèves sont
toujours meilleurs et les moins bons
élèves sont toujours moins beau et donc
on a le système le plus inégalitaire qui
existe d'où toute la politique qui est
faite aujourd'hui sur le primaire et sur
concentré concentration de moyens là où
il y en a besoin ça peut être des
besoins ta réduire les moyens c'est
l'inquiétude de natalité et à réduire
les moyens ailleurs notamment dans les
classes plus supérieur il n ya pas de il
n'y a pas de réduction de moyens
il ya eu effectivement une suppression
de poste de 800 postes de mémoire
d'enseignant dans le second degré qui
est compensée par des heures
supplémentaires
pourquoi est ce que le ministère a fait
ce choix tout simplement c'est parce que
dans le secondaire il ya une bulle bull
démographique
aujourd'hui dans le premier degré le il
ya une baisse démographique importante
chaque année et à la rentrée prochaine
malgré l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans
le premier degré perd des élèves et donc
ça va arriver dans le secondaire on va
constater une baisse démographique qui
n'a pas lieu pour le moment donc on
préfère pour le moment proposé
effectivement compensation par heure
supplémentaire et on sait qu'ensuite on
constatera dans le second degré la
baisse démographique qu'on constate
aujourd'hui dans le premier degré un
choix du monde c'est vous que les
enseignants qui nous pose des questions
on le constate une pénurie d'enseignants
je vous lis pas une réaction d'anne
laure la pénurie d'enseignants continue
pourquoi le gouvernement at il baissé le
nombre de recrutements cette année
vous dites 800 en moins moi j'avais
j'avais vu sur le budget 2010 9,2 à 2650
postes en moins sur collèges lycées
contre 1800 recrutement dans le primaire
ce qui fait une perte sèche de 800 2650
postes qui ne sont pas forcément des
postes d'enseignants donc
donc il faut faire aussi y'a pas que des
enseignants dans le secondaire
mais l'un dans l'autre de toute façon la
baisse dans le secondaire la baisse de
postes est compensée par les heures
supplémentaires dans le premier degré au
contraire on a une baisse démographique
et ont créé des postes justement pour
améliorer le taux d'encadrement et avoir
des classes avec moins d'élèves
nathalie faire alors il y à des
suppressions de postes sèche et il ya
effectivement des suppressions de postes
partiellement compensée par des heures
supplémentaires
pourquoi parce que dans l'enseignement
une ourse supplémentaire et moins
rémunérés qu'une heure poste donc le
ministre fait bien des économies sur
notre dos je tiens tout de même à
préciser que ça n'est pas la même chose
et que du coup le taux d'encadrement va
baisser puisque on va simplement demandé
aux profs d'en faire plus c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que jean michel
blanquer a rappelé poser une deuxième
heure supplémentaire à tous les profs il
y a donc une vraie volonté de faire des
économies tout comme le recrutement de
surveillants
pour faire court puisque maintenant dans
leur nouveau statut les a aidés pour on
a eu des dons qu les surveillants à son
rang
les assistants d'éducation pour ont
petit à petit faire court pour une pour
un salaire très modiques et donc combler
les trous béants de recrutement auquel
le ministère est confronté et par
rapport à aux inégalités
il faut voir que le ministre va
renforcer les inégalités géographiques
et sociales à la fois par la réforme du
lycée et par la loi pour l'école de la
confiance
je m'explique rapidement on reviendra je
vous promets d'ici la fin de l'émission
spécifiquement sur la réforme du lycée
mais sur l'école de la confiance en quoi
les inégalités sont elles renforcées eh
bien on va graver dans le marbre
l'existence de sections internationales
qui seront financés à la fois par des
subsides privé public et on va également
gravé dans le marbre a les enseignements
des savoirs fondamentaux qui sont en un
regroupement par réseau d'écoles
primaires et de collèges et on sait tous
très bien que la mise en réseau des
écoles
des collèges c'est pour faire des
économies d'échelle et que à terme ça va
se solder par la fermeture de locaux
dans les petites écoles rurales
sandrine claude est ce que les familles
partagent les craintes des enseignants
oui sur bien des points on évoque donc
le projet de loi de l'école de la
confiance alors tout le monde n'a
peut-être pas pris le temps de lire
mais l'article 1er vaut son pesant de
cancoillotte j'ai envie de vous dire
alors franc-comtois dans le texte c'est
exactement ça par leur engagement et
leur exemplarité les personnels de la
communauté éducative contribuer à
l'établissement du lien de confiance qui
doit unir les élèves et leurs familles
au service public de l'éducation
voilà mais à aucun moment il n'est est
écrit que la réciproque doit être vraie
alors madame la députée vous évoquiez il
ya un malentendu dans votre rapport
simplement les mots ont un sens et quand
ils n'y sont pas le doute est plus que
permis on met de côté les familles
fletcher mieux pas du tout et dans cet
article premier qui je le rappelle n'a
pas de portée normative se dire qu'il
n'ajoute rien par rapport à l'obligation
de neutralité qui est déjà dû pour tous
les fonctionnaires
il ya effectivement une précision de
l'exemplarité des enseignants il ya
également la communauté éducative qui
est impliqué est également l'institution
je pense qu'il est important de rappeler
c'est un simple rappel en fait d'une
évidence
des relations qui devrait prévaloir
entre l'institution
les enseignants la communauté éducative
jérémy vouloir 24 élèves par classe est
il raisonnable quand il n'y a pas assez
de salles on parlait du nombre
d'enseignants il ya aussi des problèmes
très concrets
c'est la place bien sûr comment fait-on
bien sûr alors on a eu déjà un
aménagement sur les dédoublements de
classes cp ce1 en reste onze journées
prioritaires lanta fait qui a demandé
beaucoup d'investissement dans les
villes concernées et il était évident
que sur le 24 élèves par classe donc en
dehors des zones rep y compris en
réalité il va falloir des aménagements
et encore une fois c'est un objectif se
dire qu'à la rentrée 2010 9 on n'aura
pas de nom n'aura pas 24 élèves par
classe partout pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement il y a un enjeu de
salles et donc il va falloir réfléchir à
comment est-ce qu'on accompagne les
collectivités pour pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre cette disposition est également
un enjeu sur les enseignants se serait
on est on est bien évidemment objet de
lisser le recrutement des enseignants
que ça nécessitera sandrine claude ces
problématiques très concrète de place de
nombre de salles disponibles j'imagine
que les familles sont sensibles et
parents d'élèves
les familles sont très sensibles et nous
militants encore plus notant que là
c'est un problème qui va se poser pour
le premier degré mais qui se pose par
exemple déjà dont nous lis et je pense
au laboratoire de langues aux sciences
ou divers ateliers informatiques
on a parfois parfois pas assez de pas
assez de postes
pas assez de paillasse se passer
d'ordinateur éducation nationale n'a pas
les moyens de ses ambitions
ça vous êtes en train de nous dire
combien j'ai envie de vous dire un petit
peu même si madame la député rappelait
très justement de toute façon que nous
avons la chance d'être le premier budget
de l'état
mais pour autant on peut quelquefois
aussi s'interroger sur la distribution
des moyens ça c'est aussi une question
qu'il faut se poser et je rejoindre ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur sur
l'économie il ya un article du projet de
loi qui a fait polémique que c'était
l'article 6 si ma mémoire est bonne et
qui est supprimée qui va être
vraisemblablement retravaillé et qui
commet qui évoquait la possibilité de
faire quand même des regroupements dans
les zones rurales qui dit regroupement
dit quand même économie en revient
toujours la france c'est pas
nécessairement un regroupement physique
l'article 6 dans madame
viens de viens de parler c'est un nouvel
établissement un établissement n'est pas
forcément sur un seul et même site et
l'idée n'est pas du tout de faire des
économies mais de travailler à la
liaison entre le premier et le second
degré et particulièrement au sein d'un
cycle qui est à cheval un jeu rappelle
le travail c'est du cm1 jusqu'à la
sixième c'est de pouvoir travailler à
des projets pédagogiques de manière à
mieux articuler cette liaison entre deux
établissements effectivement où
l'arrivée d'ado janvier ce que redoutent
les enseignants c'est d'être mis sous la
tutelle déjà de la suppression des
directeurs d'école et puis d'être mis
sous la tutelle de collège par les
enseignants du premier degré des écoles
les établissements des savoirs
fondamentaux première chose il ya aucun
aucun établissement force et c'est à
l'initiative du territoire c'est une
convention entre les collectivités
territoriales etc
on n'ira pas en créer quand les
enseignants la communauté éducative ne
le souhaite pas ça n'est pas une remise
en cause du directeur d'école aucunement
est au contraire la volonté est plutôt
globalement de renforcer
de renforcer le directeur d'école danser
dans ses fonctions vous êtes rassurés
nathalie faivre absolument l'occasion
absolument pas déjà vouloir mettre les
écoles sous la coupe des collèges est
très mal venue parce que les
vocabulaires et le choix de vos mots est
contestée par fabre servier s'est tout
de même bien ce qui est continu continu
dans le projet puisque il était envisagé
la création d'un principal adjoint qui
serait chargée de chapeauter toutes les
écoles du réseau
donc il s'agit bien de créer une
nouvelle hiérarchie intermédiaire pour
chapeauter les écoles or les directeurs
d'école existent ils sont issus d'une
tradition de cooptation entre collègues
et nous nos collègues du premier degré y
tiennent beaucoup parce que ça permet un
travail entre pères et il est hors de
question pour eux de renoncer à ce mode
d'organisation qui fait partie de leurs
habitudes et qui est efficace et le mode
de gouvernance verticale du second degré
avec un proviseur ou un principal qui
donne des ordres et des enseignants qui
exécutent est quelque chose qui crée
beaucoup de conflits à l'heure actuelle
et il nous paraît très mal venu de
vouloir l'appliquer au premier degré un
témoignage de raphaël directrice de
maternelle
on m'a explicitement demandé
d'accueillir les enfants de petite
section avec des couches dès la rentrée
prochaine
comment je fais pour gérer les couches
et des changes lorsque j'ai une heure
d'atsem dans la journée s de la
bienveillance envers les enfants de les
laisser attendre avec une couche salle
le temps que quelqu'un se libère pour
l'échangé c'est ça la réalité du terrain
annette charles et que répondez vous à
cette directrice de l'école
alward s'est c'est effectivement une
difficulté qu'on a pointé nous dès qu'on
a eu connaissance du prix du pré projet
de loi c en octobre l'an dernier sur
comment faire face à des enfants qui
sont pas propres la plupart du temps la
propreté elle se résout en quelques
semaines dans la majeure partie des cas
et ont même quelques ménages et même
quelques semaines fanette chars bien
c'est des situations auxquelles sont
confrontés les enseignants et on peut
aménager et on peut aménager du coup
parfois la présence de l'enfant
on n'a pas souhaité émettre des
exceptions dans la loi sur l'obligation
d'instruction à trois ans parce que
sinon ça fausse complètement le message
et la symbolique donc l'instruction elle
était obligatoire à partir de 3 ans il
est évident que dans certains cas et je
pense qu'il faut que ça reste du cas par
cas on puisse avoir des aménagements et
là on travaille avec l'éducation
nationale avec les collectivités
territoriales puisque effectivement en
école maternelle les atsem se sont elles
sont embauchés par les maisons il faut
évidemment pouvoir éventuellement
prévoir des aménagements mais c'est du
cas par cas
ça relève pas de la loi je vous donne la
parole nathalie fait mais on a
énormément de questions sur la
rémunération des professeurs c'est une
avalanche vous dordogne tune mathieu qui
nous lie quand à l'ignorer vous la
rémunération des enseignants sur les
autres fonctionnaires d'état catégorie à
évidemment c'est une revendication
lancinante des enseignants est ce que
vous voyez le bout du tunnel sur cette
question là ça fait 20 ans qu'on
constate une lente dégradation du
pouvoir d'achat des
et des enseignants et pour vous donner
une idée le salaire de départ d'un
enseignant c'est à dire bac + 4/5 c'est
mille quatre cent mille 500 euros
c'est-à-dire atteignent plus que le smic
le salaire moyen
oui oui tout enseignants confondus en
début de charisme non là vous parlez du
début de carrière le salaire moyen je
précise les 2400 60 euros nets
oui sur l'ensemble du corps professoral
ce qui nous place bien en queue de
peloton des pays comparables en europe
c'est deux fois moins qu'en allemagne ou
en suisse voisine et ça explique la
crise de recrutement donc la faiblesse
des salaires plus les difficultés
d'exercice du métier font que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui ne veulent plus se tourner
vers le métier d'enseignant est donc à
un moment donné le ministère sera au
pied du mur il faudra bien revaloriser
le métier
si on veut continuer à avoir un prof
devant chaque est ce qu'on peut demander
aux enseignants de réformer comme ça
arrête de ceux de tout changer
régulièrement parce que c'est quand même
le cas il ya les réformes de l'éducation
nationale tout le temps avec ses niveaux
de salaires la fenêtre janvier il est
évident que sur la partie salaires on a
encore beaucoup d'efforts à faire
la masterisation d'ailleurs n'a pas
forcément été compensés sur quoi avons
recrutés à bac + 3 on recrute à bac + 5
n'a pas forcément été suivies d'effet en
matière de hausse de rémunération et on
a énormément de choses encore à faire il
ya des choses qu'ils ont déjà été
lancées sous le quinquennat précédent
qui se poursuivent aujourd'hui je pense
sur la gestion des carrières avec la
création d'une classe exceptionnelle
et puis on va s'atteler justement sur le
début de carrière c'est à dire que
rentrer à l'horizon 2020 un certifié
stagiaires en début de carrière c'est
1000 euros annuels supplémentaires pour
le pour le débit carrière on ne peut pas
tout rattrapé d'un coup on peut pas tout
gober d'un coup mais il ya des efforts
qui sont faits je pense également à la
prime rep vers un moment donné
récompenser ceux qui s'engagent dans des
établissements réputés difficiles
il ya aussi une reconnaissance qu'on
peut trouver en fonction des engagements
qui sont nos restes d'une poignée de
minutes j'aimerais qu'on
un peu de la réforme du lycée qui va
rentrer en qui va commencer en septembre
prochain
fini les filières l s et es
le problème c'est que tous les
établissements ne vont pas pouvoir
proposer l'intégralité des nouvelles
spécialités du coup les petits lycée en
zone rurale notamment se sentent
fragilisés
certains de leurs élèves ont retrouvé le
bonheur ailleurs jérémy nous dit
pourquoi le ministre dit il que les
élèves pourront choisir leur spécialité
alors qu'en fait tous les lycées ne
propose pas toutes les spécialités
c'est un problème très concret auquel
les familles les parents d'élèves sont
confrontés quel est votre point de vue
là dessus sandrine claude un jour jérémy
a tout à fait raison à la formulation de
sa question
c'est exactement ce que nous avons vécu
à la fin du trimestre dernier au moment
des conseils de classe du 2è trimestre
où nos élèves de seconde via les fiches
navettes devait formuler des voeux pour
des spécialités l'année prochaine on a
demandé donc aux enfants de formuler des
voeux en n'ayant pas encore puisque on a
l'impression aussi qui est une espèce de
mercato permanent en n'ayant pas non
plus forcément la vision de toutes les
spécialités soit dans leurs propres
établissements soit dans les
établissements de leur ville quand on
ouvre comme ça une boîte merveilleuse en
disant c'est la liberté de choix il faut
vraiment que ça soit le cas
or là ça ne l'est pas on a pu le
contacter et de le constater avec
plusieurs plusieurs familles et on a des
choses tout à fait aberrantes on a des
familles qui nous contactent en nous
disant moi c'était l'été l'option et on
se rend compte que pour cette option que
vraiment il veut faire parce que c'est
ce qui va lui servir
dans la pas d'autre choix que de partir
être en internat évidemment ça paraît
être un cas extrême mais c'est bien des
choses qui existent
et puis la difficulté aussi quand même
de ce choix de spécialités c'est qu'on
demande aujourd'hui un choix alors que
les attendus du supérieur ne sont
toujours pas communiqué et qu'il n'est
pas non plus très visible pour les
familles le fait d'avoir abandonné une
des spécialités en fin de première n'est
pas forcément visible pour tout le monde
donc elle pour construire un projet
d'orientation c'est quand même
relativement saugrenue sans parler de
l'âge des élèves
datalift je vois hocher la tête depuis
deux minutes vous êtes d'accord avec
tout ce qu'a dit votre voisine a mais
complètement cette réforme du lycée
dramatique pour les élèves et elle va
elle aussi générer une accentuation des
inégalités géographiques et sociales et
pourtant jean michel blanquer redis je
n'ai rencontré que des élèves de 2de
heureux alors là il l'a pas dire très
enthousiastes ou les lycées ont amélioré
leurs offres
je vois des élèves de 2de présent tout y
est non non c'est pas vrai la clinique
beaucoup de lycées notamment les petits
lycée de notre académie est une offre
qui s'est appauvrie allez demander aux
collègues du lycée de gré ou de luxeuil
ou du lycée follereau s'ils sont
contents ils vont vous dire que l'offre
est plus est plus réduite jeu-là
ciellement on a on n'a pas deuxièmement
on laisse répondre juste fenêtre servier
je suis désolé d'arriver à la fois des
missions
il ya quand même un problème
d'aménagement du territoire avec cette
réforme du lycée madame charvier non je
vais essayer de faire concis parce que
je vois qu'on a plus beaucoup de temps
pensez-vous qu évidemment la réforme du
lycée plus de choix puisqu'on passe de
filières un panachage à la carte pour
les pour les pour les lycéens
et c'est également plus de choix je
rappelle simplement qu'aujourd'hui tous
les lycées ne propose pas les trois
séries scientifiques littéraires
économique
on a aujourd'hui 15% le lycée qui ne
proposent pas les trois séries demain
les sept spécialités de base seront
proposés dans 92 % des lycées c'est donc
une amélioration de l'offre
merci on vous réconciliera pas j'ai bien
compris merci à toutes les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission dans un
instant votre flash d'information en
région puis la suite de dimanche en
politique
francis letellier reçoivent un nombril à
tête de liste de la france insoumise aux
européennes bon dimanche à tous